[Music]
two more few minutes for yourself
do you want me just to go go the most
shocking finale in bachelor history what
is your reaction to the way that Arie
handled his breakup with Becca all I
could do was sitting there watching like
just leave Arie like just go and he
didn't leave he wouldn't leave and I
think that's where I was feeling very
awkward and like I'm sure that situation
with him was difficult and I'm sure for
her it was difficult but I didn't know
what he what else he was trying to get
out of it it was like he needed him sit
like he needed her to reassure him that
everything was gonna be okay it's it's
not gonna happen right now because it
was obviously a shocking breakup her and
this helped the further along we got the
further I started drifting away from the
possibility of trying it again with her
well yeah because that's a normal
relationship there's a level of me to
that's watching this saying like why
does this have to happen with cameras
were like what why can't this beast just
be done in a private moment away from
everybody do you think that Arie should
have done it on camera yeah I do but I
also get the idea that you know if as
viewers if he's committed to allowing us
into his love story that some of his
love story involves this and so I
understand his thought process was this
might be the best option for now and and
taking so I don't have to explain this
through interview maybe we just do it on
on camera I understand that but I felt
like I was watching something that I did
not need to be a part of
[Music]